now on book TV an analysis of the
relationship between Soviet and East
German leaders during the Cold War with
hope Harrison author of driving the
Soviets up the wall this talk from the
International Spy Museum in Washington
DC is an hour and a half I think you're
going to very much enjoy this evenings
presentation I've had a chance to meet
dr. Harrison as well as get some sense
of the extraordinary scholarship that
she has put into this book one of the
things that I find I don't know I think
everybody approaches books differently
but I always look for authors to sort of
catch those magical phrases that come up
in their lives when they're working on a
book or experiencing whatever it is
they're writing about I had the very
surreal experience of having been in the
Cold War for some thirty six years of
sitting in an office at CIA at Langley
in headquarters and watch the tearing
down of the wall in Berlin and I can
tell you it was truly a very surreal
experience it was one that myself and my
colleagues never thought we would see we
had the same experience when the Soviet
Union dissolved and so it was just
something it was a war that we thought
would never end and there were many I
think myths during that war some of
which I think dr. Harrison addresses
very well but let me just give you a
flavor of what the young dr. Harrison
was experiencing and she opens her book
by saying on the afternoon of nine
November I boarded a plane on a long
planned journey to West Berlin I was
going with a group of graduate students
from Harvard and Stanford for 10 days on
a program sponsored by the city of West
Berlin during the night of Thursday 9
November our group flew it to Frankfurt
and when we boarded the connecting
flight to West Berlin on Friday morning
everyone on the plane was reading
newspapers with banner head
declaring the wall is open I looked
around and thought is 10 November the
equivalent of April Fool's Day in
Germany what is going on I didn't have
to wonder for long the pilot got on the
intercom system and announced and I love
this phrase the wall fell in Berlin last
night we are flying into history that's
a very moving phrase and I think
encapsulated so much of what so many of
us fell as you flew into history we were
experiencing it in different ways I
think for me the significance of this
book as much as anything is dr. Harrison
through her scholarship has changed the
picture of so many of us who experienced
the cold world war war felt about so
many of the satellites Bulgaria Romania
certainly East Berlin and that is that
they were merely that that they were
satellites there were puppets there were
countries on a string as it were and she
looks so thoroughly into this she
exploited right after the fall of the
wall she was able to exploit both
Russian and German archives and she is
fluent in both Russian and German and
was able to determine that whereas so
many of us thought the erection of the
wall was probably a Soviet idea a Soviet
initiative Soviet momentum indeed it was
not that in fact it was an idea and I
certainly don't want to take any of your
of your thunder but the idea is so
extraordinary that this actually sprang
from within the country and indeed met
with some resistance by the Soviets and
so often I find that when we look at
these countries that are so dominated by
another one we tend to forget that the
people who are dominated or occupied
also often have power and influence
whether it was Cyprus where I also
served where we we always thought of the
Greek Cypriots and the and the Turkish
Cypriots as mere puppets of mainland
Greece and of mainland Turkey not the
case and we certainly thought of it as
we looked at the two Koreas in the two
Viet Nam's
and I think even today as we look at
Iraq and what we're experiencing there
we forget sometimes that it is not as
simple not as black and white as it so
often looks on CNN and on the other
media which portray things and make them
easily digestible sometimes their
digestive all but they part from reality
a word on dr. Harrison now she holds her
undergraduate degree in social studies
from Harvard and a political science
degree from Columbia excuse me a PhD
from Columbia in political science she
isn't as she is currently an associate
professor at George Washington
University since 1999 in the Department
of History and the Elliot School of
International Affairs she's also a
senior research fellow with the Cold War
international history project she has as
I mentioned done the research into the
archives in both Berlin and Moscow and
she was for a period 2000 to 2001 the
director for European and Eurasian
affairs in the National Security Council
at the White House and she lectures
quite extensively on Soviet foreign
policy the Cold War Germany in the Cold
War international affairs and this one I
like the uses and misuses of history in
international affairs I think it would
be a particular privilege to be a
student of yours her contribution to
scholarship is extraordinary the award
she's been granted the papers she's done
and the conference's to which she has
spoken so it is indeed a pleasure to
have you here
dr. Harrison please help me welcome dr.
Harris
wanna come around
thank you so much for that absolutely
wonderful introduction I really
appreciate it
Peter and thank you for coming tonight
after probably a hard day of work for
many of you so I'll do my best to keep
you engaged and I particularly want to
thank my father and my dear friends
Devin and Hal for coming tonight and I
want to thank the spy museum this is a
fantastic museum a wonderful addition to
Washington I teach many classes on the
Cold War at George Washington University
but one of them is on the two Germany's
and the Cold War and I brought my class
here and they had a fantastic time
because so many of the things that we
had talked about in class are in fact
illustrated here such as the kind of car
that would have smuggled out people
trying to escape from East Berlin into
West Berlin part of the Berlin tunnel
all sorts of fantastic things here at
the International Spy Museum that really
give you a flavor of what it was like to
be in Berlin during the Cold War as well
as so many other things of course so I'm
I'm very grateful for the invitation to
speak here and to you all for coming
well the Berlin Wall is of course the
symbol of the Cold War it's going up in
1961 indicated that this was a serious
long-term conflict that wasn't going to
go away and of course it's fall in 1989
was really the beginning of the end of
the Cold War and was obvious to all yet
the Berlin wall of course was far more
than a symbol it was in fact really a
very living thing with all the border
guards the dogs at the border preventing
people from the East leaving to go to
the West without permission I want to
remind us all tonight what we're really
talking about when we talk about the
and when we talk about the communist
decision to build the Berlin wall so I
want to show the first tape that will
really show you in the most harsh
reality what we're talking about when we
consider the Berlin wall and backed it
with fences tripwires
and tank traps
during the first year 50 Germans died
trying to cross to the west one of them
was 18 year old Peter Fechter the
Americans gathered the soldiers gathered
on one side not doing anything and on
the other side the GDR the purpose the
idea police there was standing on their
side not doing anything and this young
man was huddled I remember he was lying
like an s-shape and first he screamed he
cried he shouted for help and as the
hours went on his boys got weaker and
weaker
it was so hard rendering that in the
middle of nowhere was a human being
dying and two groups was pacing each
other too worried to act because they
didn't know what the other one was going
to do it was it was it was really
horrible he was just standing there and
you thought he's just dying and you
can't do anything I mean I've never been
in that situation before neither after
or you actually see a person dying and
you can't do anything and I'm sure
everyone else around me felt the same
the wall was the supreme symbol of the
Cold War's cruelty and Europe's division
its message was a bitter one whatever
happened beyond that line the West might
lament but would not interfere thank you
this is from the CNN series on the cold
war that ran a few years ago that clip
you just saw of Peter Fechter that
occurred on August 17th 1962 Peter
Fechter was 17 years old these Germans
built the wall to prevent people from
escaping but many people still tried
here in the museum you can see the car
the kind of car people tried to escape
in hiding under the hood hiding and in
the back hiding under the main part of
the car people tried to go out and hot
air balloons people some people even
built submarines to try to go under the
river or the canals in Berlin all sorts
of ways people try to escape some were
successful but many were not almost 200
people were killed actually at the wall
in Berlin trying to escape many more
were killed on the border between the
two parts of Germany now after Germany
United in 1990 some of the former top
East German political and military
leaders were put on trial and charged
with manslaughter charged for the murder
of these people who were killed crossing
the border so the issue of
responsibility of who is really to blame
for this wall is in fact a very
important one and what I'm going to talk
to you about today I'm gonna first show
you a remind you of the geography here
the map of Berlin and Germany Germany
and its capital city were divided into
four zones in the West the US Great
Britain and France had
zones of Germany that became West
Germany and they had zones of Berlin
that became West Berlin the Soviet zone
became East Germany and the Soviet zone
of Berlin of course became East Berlin
in 1952 the border between East and West
Germany was effectively closed for free
movement which meant that after 1952 now
the two German states were created in
1949 in 1952 the border between them was
closed which meant that only Berlin was
open after 1952 and the East German
leader was not happy with that as you'll
learn in the next transparency it'll
show you the layers of the border it
wasn't just a wall and in many cases it
wasn't just one wall there were almost
always two walls and sometimes even
three walls as well as trenches and
ditches and places for guard dogs to run
guard towers it was a living threatening
border regime meant to prevent anyone
from escaping and the wall itself as
you'll see here which went up in 1961
encircled West Berlin it was about a
hundred and two miles long about thirty
five of those miles were through the
center of Berlin in the center of that
picture there the average height was
almost 12 feet it broke off 192 streets
thirty-two train lines eight metro lines
three highways and various rivers and
lakes before August 13 1961 there were
many there were in fact about 81
crossing points on the border between
West Berlin and the
parts of East Berlin and East Germany
these crossing points were reduced
immediately to 11 and then ultimately
six so that as you can imagine took a
lot of men and a lot of wall and a lot
of barbed wire and cement to really make
that a tight border so this was a very
serious thing that affected the lives of
many people now why did I decide to
write this book which is called driving
the Soviets up the wall Soviet East
German relations from 1953 to 1961 it
covers the period from Stalin's death in
1953 through the building of the wall in
1961 well there were two reasons I wrote
this book the first was growing up
during the Cold War as of course Peter
knows far better than I he was very
involved wondering what was going on on
the other side on the Communist side
growing up in the US it was such a
mystery how did they think how did the
Soviet leaders in the Kremlin think how
did they make their decisions this was a
source of great curiosity to me and the
second sort of mystery to me was how
could a city and a country be divided
but particularly a city
I mean imagine I always like to tell my
students you know imagine a wall in
Washington and it happened to cut right
through the campus of George Washington
University you know you couldn't see
your friends you couldn't go to your
favorite classes but just imagine for a
second a wall going through your own
Street and the neighbors used to go have
lunch with every Saturday suddenly you
couldn't get there to say nothing of
your grandmother who you would visit
every weekend and you suddenly couldn't
get to her for a few years until finally
they let you pay money and apply for a
visa and go see her for one day so I
wanted to understand this
this crazy sort of inhuman thing the
Berlin Wall and the communist
decision-making behind it what I also
try to do in the book and what I want to
do today for you is to give you a
picture of the two personalities of the
leaders that we're talking about the
leader of the Soviet Union Nikita
Khrushchev who succeeded Joseph Stalin
and the leader of East Germany Walter
Ulbricht there were basically only two
leaders of East Germany ohlbrecht led
from the beginning from 49 through 71
and then Erich Honecker took over from
71 to 89 and almost till the fall of the
wall so I want to give you a sense of
who they were how they thought what
their involvement was in this decision
this historic decision of the Cold War
to build the Berlin wall and finally
what I want to do is give you sort of a
framework for understanding the
historical details and the personalities
and the framework is that of an alliance
relationship we're used to thinking of
the u.s. having alliances and allies and
thinking about the politics that go on
for example between the US and France or
you know the US and West Germany but I
want to talk about an alliance on the
Soviet side the Soviet East German
alliance and in fact talk about some of
the surprising ways in which a clearly
much weaker power namely East Germany
could in fact exert important influence
over a superpower the Soviet superpower
the Kremlin so that's what I'm going to
talk to you about today now initially
when I was starting my research on this
in 1987 1988 1989 I was rather bored
because for historian you need primary
sources you mean documents you want to
read the good stuff but of course we
couldn't get access to any of that
because the Cold War was on and there
was no way that a scholar from the
United States was gonna waltz into the
archives and Moscow Maurice Berlin and
get anything interesting so I was
reading everything that had been written
but was rather bore
doing it when I got on a plane and went
to West Berlin as you heard from Peter
and the wall came down now I remember
celebrating with everyone on the streets
of Berlin and they had champagne
everywhere and people were hugging and
kissing I saw many of the boarders
opening East Germans driving through
West Germans showering them with flowers
with westrom and money with champagne
was very moving everyone was so happy
and I thought no one is gonna want to
read the sad depressing story of why the
wall was built when they can now read
all these wonderful happy stories about
the wall coming down you know what am I
gonna do maybe I should rethink this but
then I thought you know maybe the very
fact of the wall coming down is going to
mean that the archives are going to be
open and I'm in fact going to get to
tell the story no one was able to tell
before about how did the Soviets and
East Germans come to the decision to
build the Berlin wall and luckily that
is what happened so over the course of
the next seven years I used five
different archives in Moscow in Berlin
in Moscow I used the archives of the
foreign ministry and the Central
Committee of the party the top
decision-making body under the Politburo
and in Berlin I use three archives the
archives of the former ruling party
socialist Unity Party the foreign
ministry archives as well as something
beloved to the spy museum the Stasi
archives those archives of the East
German secret police so I was able to
use five archives as well as interview
many former Soviet and East German
diplomats to ask them in fact to talk
about the story of the decision to build
the Berlin wall I was very lucky to be
one of the first scholars into these
archives particularly in Moscow because
in the
the Yeltsin period when there was a
really flowering of us-russian relations
the archival doors were quite open and
so I was able to get some fantastic
things that include letters back and
forth between the Soviet and East German
leaders word-for-word memorandum
conversations all sorts of high-level
fantastic documents that only two years
later were mostly closed down as Russia
became more nationalistic and thus so
did its archival policy and nobody
really was able to get these documents
not even if you were from Russia but
certainly not if you were from the West
so I was there for what we called the
Golden Age of archival access in Moscow
in 1992 in 1993 and I have included
large excerpts of documents in my book
and I'm going to in fact show you some
of those documents today well there are
two bookends framing my book the first
is the beginning in March of 1953 when
the Soviets refused an East German
request to closed the border in Berlin
and then of course it ends in 1961 where
the Soviets changed their mind and
agreed and so the book tells the story
of how was it that the Soviets changed
their mind and that the how did the East
Germans play such an important role in
getting the Soviets to change their mind
in ways that you wouldn't have expected
now
the general situation in East Germany
and East Berlin in the 1950s that gave
rise to the desire of the leader to
close the border in Berlin was of course
the refugee exodus between 1953 and 1961
over ten percent of the East German
population left the country to go west
for better working opportunities more
money more freedom
all these kinds of things and in fact it
was 15% of the working population of
East Germany so this was a real problem
something also a key part of this museum
Berlin was spy central in the Cold War
and of course this wasn't just East
Berlin but it was also West Berlin both
sides had many agents and were of course
using all the advantages of this open
city with two systems to run agents and
try to find out what was happening on
the other side and these Germans of
course didn't like this at all and
neither did the Soviets that here was
this island of Western democracy and
capitalism West Berlin was this island
surrounded by the Soviet bloc yet they
had all these listening posts to you
know pick up on the conversations in the
Warsaw Pact and the East Germans the
Soviets didn't like this at all so this
was yet another reason that we're trying
to do something sort of close down West
Berlin so the first document that I want
to share with you is what what we
historians would really call a smoking
gun you know you you work hours and
hours weeks months in the archives you
look through all sorts of boring
documents and sometimes you come up with
a great document and this was one of
them this is the Soviet refusal in March
of 1953 to these Germans I've underlined
the key things and I'm going to read it
and talk about it the Soviet refusal I'm
saying no you can't close the border in
Berlin at the bottom of the first
paragraph I've put it in caps and
underlined it they said this is
unacceptable and grossly simplistic not
we expect the Kremlin was saying but
that's what they said then in the next
paragraph in Part A they essentially say
you must be kidding Berlin is a huge
city you can't divide a huge city like
this if they say it would violate the
established order of city life
would disorganize the economy it would
negatively affect the interests of the
population and it would call forth
bitterness and dissatisfaction from the
Berliners against you East Germans and
against us the Soviets and then in the
bottom paragraph in C they say doing
this would complicate Soviet relations
with the US Great Britain and France
something we can and must avoid so you
know this isn't just sort of no we don't
think so this is no for the following
four or five reasons that are very
clearly laid out which make perfect
sense you know anyone thinking
rationally would have said this and the
Soviets said this for many years the
East German leader Walter Ulbricht
however just didn't like this answer and
kept persistently nagging and sort of
manipulating the Soviets to change their
mind now as I've made clear a key part
of this story is this ally Alliance
relationship between the strong power of
the Soviets and the weaker power these
Germans and so one of the broader points
I make in this book isn't about the
importance of allies the importance of
smaller powers during the Cold War many
people think you know the Cold War if
you just study what Washington and
Moscow did that's enough the US and the
Soviets they were the superpowers they
called all the shots that's it well yes
they weren't you obviously can't
understand it without understanding US
and Russian policy but it's insufficient
it turns out that there were other
countries that were also essential to
just some of the general dynamics of the
Cold War as well as some of the specific
events so to really understand what went
on you've got to study both the
superpowers and some of their key allies
now allies mattered in two key ways
during the Cold War the first way is
business
superpowers believed they did it's the
domino theory it's it's feeling that in
this Cold War struggle your reputation
is riding on having more allies than the
other side and if you look like you're
the one that people are coming to your
side of the fight and they're leaving
the other side you look good you don't
want to be the one that everybody's
deserting and they're looking toward
Moscow for example so for both the US
and the Soviet Union and documents from
the archives attest to this on both
sides there were key moments when they
really felt our reputation as a
superpower and as a representative of
either democracy or communism our
reputation is riding on the success of
our allies we will look bad if they
don't do well and nowhere was this more
clear than the center of the Cold War in
the two parts of Germany and the two
parts of Berlin and I'm gonna give you
some examples later but this crucial
sense that your reputation is riding on
how your German Ally does the second
reason that allies were important during
the Cold War is that they sometimes
acted independently of their superpower
patron again this isn't something you
thought of and certainly we didn't
mostly think of it during the Cold War
as Peter mentioned there was a sense
that these were puppets they were
satellites Moscow calls all the shots
but there's there's just no way you can
read the documents in the communist
archives and hold to that conclusion you
you just can't it's absolutely clear
that there were moments when East
Germany as well as Cuba as well as North
Vietnam as well as North Korea were
definitely acting independently of
Moscow and in ways that mattered for the
Cold War now with regard to these German
part of this as I write in the book I'm
talking about the leader of East Germany
Walter Ulbricht all brakes tenacity in
pursuing his goal of closing the
refugees escape
pache to West Berlin was like the
recurring drumbeat in the baseline of
the Beethoven Violin Concerto ominous
building and intensity and not always
under the conductor's control the book
is basically three case studies of
relations between the superpower Soviet
Union and East Germany and in each of
the three cases between 1953 and 1961
you see the East German leaders either
hindering stated Soviet policies from
being successfully carried out or
actively pushing the Soviets to change
their policies the first case is 1953
when the Soviets insisted the East
Germans moderate their policies feeling
that they had too harsh of a Stalinist
policy and it was leading everybody to
escape and the East German leader
totally resisted the second case was in
1956 and 57 Khrushchev's fav famous
secret speech denouncing Stalin an
incredibly courageous thing perhaps the
most courageous act anybody did during
the Cold War and as part of his
denunciation of Stalin he also called on
all of his allies to D Stalin eyes their
domestic and foreign policies and again
ohlbrecht resisted and finally the
crisis over Berlin between 1958 and 1961
where Khrushchev was trying to get an
agreement with the West on Berlin as
I'll talk about in detail Ulbricht very
much tried to act unilaterally and
undercut what Khrushchev was trying to
do so this is all not what you would
expect if you adopted the traditional
Cold War view that Moscow called the
shots in East Germany was just a
satellite with no room for autonomy now
as I mentioned the key point I want you
all to to take away is that these
smaller powers such as East Germany
played an essential role and part of
that was because of the commitment of
Nikita Kruschev to doing whatever he
could to make sure his East German Ally
looked really good
and the frontline aspect of Berlin is
what made this competition between
communism and capitalism between
communism and democracy so essential so
in the second clip I'm going to show you
you're going to get a very vivid sense
of exactly what it meant that Berlin was
at the frontline of the Cold War
this shows a street in the center of
Berlin where the houses the front of the
house was in West Burt was in East
Berlin and the back of the house was in
West Berlin so you could walk in one
door and go out the other and go to
freedom until they boarded up the
windows
helping people escape became a routine
assignment for West Berlin's fire
brigade another hazard attribute is a
straw iron that's later spring void it
became the custom but people who wanted
to escape people who wanted to leave
would throw little pieces of paper out
of the windows into Bernauer Strasse
did no margin number of the building the
floor the window the second or third
window was written on it and the time
for example 10 o'clock that they wanted
to German you know one scene where arms
were mush bring tossing belongings from
the window of an apartment overlooking
the western border and freedom an
escapee is prepared to jump to safety
into a net held by police and firemen of
West Berlin
and here is the rescue episode that is
even more extraordinary an attempt is
being made by sympathetic Germans to
assure the escape of a brave woman while
communist police tried to pull her back
through the window below there is
freedom's grip of blood killing secrets
that the news of the day camera follows
to its dramatic conclusion
hey the East Germans blocked even this
last loophole thank you so makes it very
clear this was the front line and it was
perfectly obvious you know your
reputation was riding on what was going
on the West felt good about this all
this kind of footage and of course that
the background this is clearly Western
you know freedom's gripped below you can
imagine this was not shown on communist
TV these kinds of things but some some
in the communist bloc were more willing
to recognize the problem than others
the ambassador to East Berlin from
Moscow Mikhail perversion was all too
aware of the problem he wrote back to
Moscow in 1959 he said the presence in
Berlin of an open and to speak to the
point uncontrolled border between the
socialist and capitalist worlds
unwittingly prompts the population to
make a comparison between both parts of
the city which unfortunately does not
always turn out in favor of democratic
or East Berlin so he was all too aware
given that he was posted he was the
ambassador there you know he couldn't be
hiding his head in the sand he knew what
was going on
Krisha off however the Soviet leader was
so optimistic about communism and the
communism was gonna win and it was the
superior system that it took him until
really the last minute to fully
understand that it wasn't gonna make it
on its own in East Berlin now he I mean
he recognized the problem in 1956
Khrushchev said the conflict between
socialism and capitalism precedes in
East Germany as a country with open
borders as a result particular attention
by all forces in the socialist bloc must
be directed to
word East German victory in the
competition so he's essentially saying
East Germany's at the front line
everybody's watching we have to make
sure it wins in the competition Mao
Zedong the leader of Communist China
said the same thing he said a victory in
this question is a victory of the entire
peace camp the socialist camp and a
failure would be a failure of the entire
socialist camp so you've got both crew
chef and Mao saying essentially the
reputation of communism is riding on
what happens at the frontline in East
Berlin and East Germany another sort of
smoking gun document that gives the best
flavor of how very important to
Khrushchev success in East Germany was
this is a document from Khrushchev's
closest advisor and Presidium colleague
Anna Stas Mikoyan Mikoyan went to East
Berlin in June of 1961 and he really
gave voice to the central way of
understanding how it was that
essentially East Germany could persuade
the reluctant Soviets the reluctant crew
Schaaf into changing his mind and
closing the border in this quote which
is certainly what krishna felt it makes
it very clear he says East Germany is
the westernmost outpost of the socialist
camp therefore many people look at East
Germany our Marxist Leninist theory must
prove itself in the GDR the German
Democratic Republic East Germany he goes
goes on to say Marxism was born in
Germany it must prove its correctness
and value here we must do everything so
that your development constantly and
steadily goes forward you cannot do this
alone
the Soviet Union must and will help with
this we cannot and must not lose out to
West Germany and then in the final
paragraph here sort of the key thing he
says if socialism
not win in East Germany if communism
does not prove itself its superior and
vital here then we the Soviets have not
won the issue is this fundamental to us
therefore we cannot proceed in such a
way with any other country and this is
also the reason that East Germany
occupies first place in negotiations or
credits so it's absolutely clear
reputation of communism is riding on in
crew shots views riding on the success
of East Germany and the next clip I want
to show you the final clip from the CNN
really is a fantastic demonstration of
Khrushchev's
optimism that communism is the way of
the future he tried to impress
Khrushchev with America's advances in
color television there are some
instances where you may be ahead of us
for example in the development of your
of the thrust of your rockets for the
investigation of outer space there may
be some instances for example color
television where we're out of you but in
order for both for both of us ability
Nexen was no competition for chairman
Khrushchev he generally ran the show
whenever he was around and his
incredible sort of boisterous and you
know infectious enthusiasm about
communism is vividly clear here now
you've all heard of the domino theory if
one country goes the others will go with
it others in the area such as in Vietnam
Southeast Asia
well you could call Berlin and Germany
in fact super Domino's not just Domino's
in the Cold War but super Domino's or
super Allies to the US and the Soviet
Union
each feeling that the way it's part of
Berlin and it's part of Germany fared in
the Cold War was essential to its own
reputation both on presidents Eisenhower
and Kennedy felt this way about West
Germany and West Berlin and they also
felt much frustration in their dealings
with the West German leader Konrad
Adenauer just as Khrushchev was often
very frustrated with his German Ally
Walter Ulbricht both felt that their
Germany was very very important
President Kennedy gave voice to this
when he met chairman Khrushchev in the
summit meeting in Vienna in June of 1961
Khrushchev was putting pressure on
Kennedy essentially saying you know why
don't you give up West Berlin are you
planning a war from there you know you
must be doing something bad these makes
no logical sense for you to be there why
are you there why don't you get out and
President Kennedy said if the US was
forced out of West Berlin u.s.
commitments around the world would be
seen as mere scraps of paper worthless
the world would lose confidence in the
US and its commitments and the US would
not be seen as a serious country the US
would become isolated he said I did not
become president of the United States to
make us isolated
in his eyes defending West Berlin was
the key to defending Western Europe and
he felt that if he gave up West Berlin
he would lose Western Europe very
quickly thereafter and President Kennedy
of course made that very clear to his
West German ally in the similar way the
Khrushchev often said to the East German
leader your needs are our needs so I
want to give you a bit of a sense of the
East German leader Walter Ulbricht
you've gotten somewhat of a sense of
Khrushchev committed to communism very
boisterous very emotional Khrushchev
just as you saw him all excited and
jovial there I could have shown you
another clip when the u2 went over the
Soviet Union they shot it down Francis
Gary Powers and there's an amazing clip
of Khrushchev yelling and screaming so
Khrushchev was you know passionate these
German leader Walter Ulbricht was not he
was the opposite very grey for all of
Khrushchev's color
ohlbrecht was a bureaucrat a hard-line
Stalin estaphan has no sense of humor
and was quite arrogant and really sort
of felt the Germans are more
sophisticated people than the Russians
and communism was founded in Germany
anyway and besides he had once met Lenin
which Khrushchev hadn't and will bricht
love to mention that whenever possible
so when you read the documents when you
read the letters back and forth when you
read their interactions this is not you
know
Ulbricht is not some you know supply an
ally instead he's he's very persistent
and self-assured and in fact arrogant at
times they made a very interesting pair
they were both at the front lines in
World War two
and I think the first time they met
according to crew shots biography
autobiography was at the front rubric as
many of the communists from Germany and
Europe spent much of World War two in
the Soviet Union and he was on the
Soviet side but trying to go and get and
sort of turn German soldiers to join the
Communist side and Khrushchev met him
one night over dinner and you know sort
of slapping him on the back and saying
you know so comrade ohlbrecht you know
did you recruit any spies today and you
know I mean you all know this is
supposed to be undercover anyway
ohlbrecht would have been mortified to
be you know to have it treated so
lightly and to have this discussed in
such a way and of course maybe he didn't
turn any German soldiers that day and he
maybe didn't want to talk about it but
this is sort of typical of Khrushchev
sort of getting right to it and you know
you could just see Albrecht totally
tensing up and probably not knowing what
to say to Khrushchev Lobeck was also
very opportunistic he learned to take
advantage of what was obviously crew
shots great commitment to East Berlin
and East Germany as crew Shas foreign
policy advisor olek try an auskey has
written there were periods when Moscow
was literally bombarded by messages and
phone calls from East Berlin and this
clearly drove Khrushchev sort of nuts
which is why the title of my book is
driving the Soviets up the wall because
he just wouldn't let up he just kept
pushing and pushing and pushing and
let's close the border and Khrushchev
kept saying no one of the most vivid
examples of all BRICS bossy attitude
with Khrushchev is a letter he wrote to
Khrushchev in January of 1961 about the
economic problems in East Germany about
the refugee problem and this is in the
context of him continuing to ask can't
we close the border and Khrushchev kept
saying no why don't you change your
policies
people want to stay in your country
instead of leave the country and it will
Brett kept saying you know really it
would be much easier if we just closed
the border so Albrecht took a different
tact in this letter a lengthy letter you
know like 20 pages long in which he
explains to comrade Khrushchev exactly
why the situation is so dire in East
Germany and whose fault it is and he
says you know in the years after World
War two while the West was investing in
West Germany and launched the Marshall
Plan and was giving West Germany all
sorts of aid the Soviets were practicing
a ruthless reparations policy taking
everything you could out of East Germany
and that's why we're in the situation
we're in now that's why our economy's in
dire straits that's why everyone's
leaving it's your fault so you have to
fix it
by closing the border you know if I was
shocked reading this letter I can only
imagine what brush-off thought so you
you get the picture that you know as
Peter mentioned in the introduction yes
there are obviously on the same side of
the Cold War there both communists but
they also had some different interests
and Mosca of course had broad worldwide
interests which included of course
decent relations with the West so that
there wouldn't be a nuclear war all
BRICS concern was much narrower it was
his country and East Berlin and even
more narrowly the refugee crisis you
know that was it he was obsessed with
this Khrushchev was concerned about that
that's for sure it was his most
important now I he knew it looked bad he
wanted to do something about it
but he wanted to do something about it
as well as have lots of other
constructive relations with other
countries most especially the US but
also West Germany France Great Britain
and in the midst of all of this began
the split of the Soviets with the
Chinese which was a huge poll on
Khrushchev's attend
which distracted him at times from
paying attention to Albrecht
so they had some different interests and
that is particularly clear in this one
interaction they had in June of 1959
Khrushchev had begun a crisis in Berlin
the year before demanding that
essentially the Westly of West Berlin
and sign a treaty there still had been
no treaty and in World War two with
Germany
and he wanted the West to recognize the
East German state so Khrushchev has been
putting pressure on the West he's
launched his big public campaign yet
he's a completely different person in
private in June in Moscow he has a
summit meeting with ohlbrecht and he
suddenly says to ohlbrecht
the opposite of what in fact he's doing
in public he says we don't think it's
worth it now to push the West to the
wall we don't want to give the
impression we are seeking Western
recognition of the East German state the
Americans don't want to recognize East
Germany they can't do this for prestige
reasons and besides we would be offended
they didn't recognize us for 16 years
and you want them to recognize you after
10 you have to wait at least 17 years I
mean if there was ever a document that
illustrates different interests of these
two powers this is it and you know you
can imagine the dour ohlbrecht being
appalled and very angry at this his ally
isn't quite measuring up here so
Albrecht begins to get frustrated or we
could say much more frustrated than he
has been for years of getting a refusal
to close the border so in the final year
before the wall is built he steps up the
pressure
and these are again some of the most
fascinating smoking gun documents found
in both Moscow and East Berlin about
impending East German unilateral moves
to close the border and Berlin in spite
of the Soviets telling them no so there
are two documents here in the one at the
top
it's October of 1960 and the second
secretary at the Soviet embassy in East
Berlin cosmonaut cables back to Moscow
and he says our friends are studying the
possibility of stopping the exodus of
the population of East Germany through
West Berlin one of such measures by our
friends could be the cessation of free
movement through the sectoral border he
goes on to say given that this would
have consequences for our work in West
Berlin it would be expedient to discuss
with our German friends at the
appropriate level the question of the
regime on the sectoral border in Berlin
so he's saying look all of a sudden on
their own the East Germany seems the
East Germans want to close off this
border well if they do that obviously
the West is going to retaliate and it's
going to be a lot harder for Soviet
diplomats to go into West Berlin and do
all sorts of things diplomacy and
espionage of course
so Khrushchev rights to ohlbrecht and
says I know you're very upset it's it's
a difficult situation but don't do
anything he writes after the elections
when President Kennedy has been elected
in November of 1966 there's a new
American president I am going to want to
talk to him about Berlin and in fact I
have told him I won't do anything in
Berlin to change anything until I talk
to him so I've given President you know
president-elect Kennedy my word so don't
do anything and I'll meet with you in
Moscow so November 30th 1960 ohlbrecht
and Khrushchev meet in Moscow and
Khrushchev says I understand
it's terrible what's going on the
refugees the the espionage all the
economic difficulties I agree with you
and we're gonna ultimately have to do
something but not now don't do anything
I want to wait to talk to President
Kennedy after which ulbrich writes that
wonderful haughty letter I told you
about a month and a half after that and
he keeps being told don't do anything
finally in the spring Khrushchev and
Kennedy set a date for their summit
meeting they're gonna meet in Vienna at
the beginning of June and Khrushchev
says to Albrecht point-blank don't do
anything before I meet with President
Kennedy so then you have the second
document which is two weeks before he's
going to meet with President Kennedy the
Soviet ambassador in East Berlin cables
back in a panic to foreign minister
Gromyko in Moscow and he says our
friends would like to establish now such
control and the sectoral border between
Democratic and West Berlin which would
allow them to as they say close the door
to the west and reduce the exodus of the
population from East Germany he goes on
in the second bottom paragraph to say
our German friends sometimes exercise
impatience and is somewhat one-sided
approach to the problem not always
studying the interests of the entire
socialist camp or the international
situation at the given moment evidence
of this for example is their efforts to
stop free movement between East your
East Germany and West Berlin as soon as
possible
by any means so you can imagine
Khrushchev was not happy to get this two
weeks before he's supposed to meet with
Kennedy and it looks like
ohlbrecht isn't going along with the
plan of not doing anything again
ohlbrecht is told don't do anything I'm
about to meet with Kennedy
so Khrushchev and Kennedy meet in Vienna
and the item on the agenda is West
Berlin and I already read to you what
President Kennedy said you know we are
not leaving and Khrushchev was even sort
of more aggressive
then Kennedy was saying we are staying
in East Berlin West Berlin is rightfully
really a part of East Germany and he
basically threatened President Kennedy
with war over this and he said we are
going to sign a treaty with East German
government that will turn over to them
control of the all-important Western
access routes across the hundred and ten
miles of East German territory the
routes that got you from West Germany to
West Berlin President Kennedy took him
aside after lunch with only the
translators there he said look I want to
be perfectly clear are you telling me
you are gonna turn over control of those
access routes our way of getting into
West Berlin are you saying you're gonna
turn those over to East Germany because
if you are it Means War and Khrushchev
said that is what I'm saying so it was a
terrible meeting in Vienna and after
Khrushchev left there he finally gave
Ulbricht the go-ahead he had been hoping
he would come up with some some sort of
agreement although what you know
rationally it was hardly likely that
President Kennedy and chairman
Khrushchev were going to come up with
some compromise on Berlin given that
they had such different views and at
long last
Khrushchev gave in to Albrecht another
one minister Andrei Gromyko
yes okay okay yes so this is from the
Stasi archives the East German secret
police archives you see in the middle of
the page
Rosa Rose the codename for closing the
border in Berlin the codename for
essentially building the Berlin Wall was
rose now once the border was closed on
the night between August 12th and August
13th it was a Saturday night a warm you
know August weekend most people were out
at their country houses out in the
forests and lakes of Berlin they weren't
in town happened in the middle of the
night you know it was fairly easy people
weren't going to stop them and caught
everyone by surprise including the
people at the CIA in West Berlin with
whom I have spoken at length about this
everyone was caught off guard including
these German people initially Khrushchev
said go gradually and see how the West
responds so they started with barbed
wire and lo and behold how did the West
respond barely at all except for West
Berlin mayor Billy Brandt who was
absolutely outraged and sort of yelled
and screamed as much as he possibly
could but President Kennedy was on you
know on vacation at Hyannis poured out
on his boat talked to his advisors he
said in confidence to his advisors a
wall as a hell of a lot better than a
war he had been very worried that this
refugee Exodus was going to somehow
escalate
military was going to get involved the
West German military was going to try to
somehow open the border and then NATO
would have to get involved President
Kennedy had been very worried so he
essentially felt this is a defensive
measure they've put up this barbed wire
all on East German territory they
haven't touched West Berlin yes its
surrounding West Berlin but it isn't
touching the soil of West Berlin
so the West sent protest notes but that
was it the East Germans and Soviets
absolutely congratulated each other they
said the adversary took fewer
countermeasures than anticipated you
know they said they had no idea this you
know we caught them completely by
surprise and then in fact the u.s.
reached out to resume talks about
Germany with the Soviets so the the
Communists were very relieved now once
it was clear the West wasn't going to
stop it the question was do we just
leave the barbed wire or do we in fact
build a wall now believe it or not the
East German military leaders favored the
barbed wire they said a barbed wire it's
totally transparent you can see easily
if someone is coming up to it and trying
to escape a wall cast shadows someone we
could come right up could be in the
shadow of the wall we wouldn't know and
they could somehow get over quickly we
prefer the barbed wire and Olbrich said
no way it invites people to escape it
invites people to break through I won a
rock solid cement wall and that's what
he got but the Soviets were still
worried even afterwards about
controlling their East German Ally and a
month after the border was closed in
late September Khrushchev wrote to
Albrecht and he said we are beginning
talks with the US with Secretary of
State Rusk in New York about Germany
therefore such steps which could
exacerbate the situation especially in
Berlin should be avoided in this
connection it is especially appropriate
to abstain from new measures which could
change the control order set up by the
East German government on the border
with West Berlin
so Khrushchev was still worried and
therefore he decided he would stop with
just clothes
the board around West Berlin he decided
not to carry out his threat of turning
over control of the access routes
between West Germany and West Berlin to
the East German leader the East German
leader of course wanted control over
those so he could shut down all the
flights carrying the refugees out and
all the cars carrying the refugees out
Khrushchev decided he wanted to be the
one to control the level of tension
between the Soviets and the West and he
didn't want Albrecht to so in essence
Ulbricht
achieved the height of his influence
with Moscow in getting them to close the
border in Berlin but also sort of lost
any influence thereafter by how he did
it because he had been so persistent so
hot a so unilateral at times that the
Soviets felt he was too risky and
wouldn't give him anything else thank
you very much
I think the most appropriate closing
words you could have used was I rest my
case
I was a brilliant presentation it
reminded me I was as I was listening up
the of the guns of August where we had a
chance many many years later to look
back at all the misunderstandings and
gaps that led to of course World War one
in this case it's extraordinary to see
this glimpse into the thinking that went
into the erection of the wall what I
would like to do is go ahead and do Q&A
we have microphones on either side so
I'll try and get a balance between these
why don't we start with you two things
one you arrived at just the right time
so did you get a piece of the wall and
secondly now that we're going through
another wall building episode in the
Middle East you have any insight from
Berlin's experience to Israel's attempt
thank you very much yes of course I got
several pieces the wall when I was there
but interestingly I also got more pieces
this past spring I spent the spring as a
fellow at the American Academy in Berlin
working on my second book which looks at
how the Germans have been coming to
terms with East Germany's past what
they've done with the leaders with the
Stasi files this kind of thing and what
they've done with the remains of the
wall which is tear down most of it of
course but there's some pieces some
pieces that are left and in fact there
you know it's actually easier than you
might think to to stroll around what
used to be no man's land and pick up
some big pieces of the wall so I got
another big piece recently I have
actually thought a fair amount about
this Israeli wall or fence and you know
any similarities or differences with of
course the Berlin wall I mean mostly
there differences so many differences
you know the East Berlin wall was built
to keep people in the Israeli walls to
keep you know people out suicide bombers
particularly out but there's one thing I
think they have very much in common
which is that they're both at the front
line of the
International conflict of the period and
they also both have behind them a
reluctant superpower you know as I've
made clear the Soviets were very
reluctant to allow the East Germans to
close the border in Berlin and the US
has also been reluctant I mean we've
gone along but you know we know full
well just as the Soviets knew full well
we look bad
and Khrushchev wrote in his memoirs you
know I knew that by building this wall
people would say what kind of us workers
and peasants paradise is this if you
have to wall people in and certainly at
the beginning of the building of this
fence President Bush and Secretary of
State Powell were you know making a lot
of public statements initially saying
you know this isn't a good idea of
course they've given in and I think it's
it's a similar dynamic in that they both
feel both the Soviets with these Germans
in the US with Israel feel you know this
is our crucial ally at the front line of
a global conflict and we don't like what
they're doing but we feel that our
relationship with them is so important
that we can't or we don't really want to
stop them there is a book signing
afterwards that a number of the stories
that you told were so juicy that is so
filled with flavor they just run all
through the book these confrontations
with Khrushchev and and others and how
he was expelled with power and that's
that's a very vital part of your book it
was hand yes sir
since the building of the wall was
supper such a precipitous act that may
well have resulted in World War three
what gave the Soviets confidence in your
research did you come across anything
that gave the them pre wall confidence
that the West would really not do
anything that I've often wondered you
know if there was a smoking gun perish
the phrase you know out of Vienna that
that was part of the the backroom
conversation that well okay you do that
now
do anything mm-hmm yep that's a great
question and well Khrushchev wasn't
completely confident he was always
worried and again this is one of the
fascinating things the difference
between Khrushchev in public who was
often ranting and threatening and in
private where he was very restrained and
cautious compared to ohlbrecht
Khrushchev was always restrained in
cautious impatience and really afraid of
nuclear war again even though there he's
the one who put the missiles in Cuba and
and but on that let me just say that I
think he learned to tactical lessons
from the Berlin Wall that he applied in
Cuba but they failed in Cuba and the two
tactical lessons were we can prepare
something in secret and the West won't
stop us once they find out they prepared
the closing of the border in secret and
the West didn't stop them okay
trying to put the missiles of Cuba they
didn't quite pull that off the West
found them before the missiles were
fully operational and the US insisted
they get them out but I think he learned
those two lessons from Berlin they just
didn't work the next time so it looks
like he was very risky but in private
you know your question how how confident
was he that there would not be a war as
a result of him closing the wall closing
the border and building the wall he was
always worried I'm the way to meet
President Kennedy in Vienna both Kennedy
and Khrushchev were really worried and
I'm the way they both stopped and met
with allies Kennedy stopped and met with
de Gaulle and France and said you know
what am I gonna do how can I make
Khrushchev understand that I'm serious
and do all kind of said you know good
luck I don't know and Khrushchev stopped
in Czechoslovakian met with Novotny and
kept talking about his fear of war and
his uncertainty of this new young
President Kennedy he said said I'm 95%
certain the West will not go to war but
5% I don't know and he said we don't
know Kennedy yet the events in key
Basho he isn't very clever meaning the
Bay of Pigs fiasco but the Bay of Pigs
also showed two crews show off the
Kennedy was willing to sort of resort to
force so even though Kennedy failed it
really worried him because he thought
you know this guy he's young and kind of
aggressive and if he did it there maybe
he's gonna resort to force in Berlin
also so he and he Khrushchev in his
typical way when he met with the other
leaders of the communist bloc in early
August to sort of get a rubber-stamp
decision to close the border in Berlin
he kept saying you know the West isn't
very scary it's gonna be fun but you
never know and we must be prepared for
all eventualities but I'm sure it'll be
fun but on the other hand and this is
what crucial speech was like so he was
definitely worried and and as I read
from that one document that said the
adversary took fewer Kennard
countermeasures than anticipated you
know he was very relieved so he was very
worried he figured you know 95% he said
they won't go to war but you know if the
5% if they do we we have to be prepared
now you ask was there a signal many many
people have have wondered this wasn't
there some you know secret agreement in
which Kennedy basically said we know
you've got a crisis with the refugees we
understand the problem you know as long
as you deal with that in a defensive way
and don't touch West Berlin you know
we'll let it go that that did not occur
but Kennedy sure made it clear over and
over especially at Vienna but also in
his speech on July 25th and in letters
he made it very clear don't touch our
access to West Berlin and don't touch
West Berlin he always talked about West
Berlin so if you're looking closely
you're noticing he's not talking about
East Berlin and he's not talking about
moving back and forth between East and
West Berlin and Khrushchev was watching
closely so he certainly you know would
have felt Kennedy's concern
is West Berlin and the access routes to
it and that's why he did not give in
when Khrushchev said give me control
over those access routes there was no
way he was going to do that yes right
here awesome presentation if you would
have been my professor I may have
learned a little more would you please
share a little more about how you came
to get access to the documents and being
a woman did that have anything to do
with it like these Romeo spies or
something well um
access to the documents I generally in
these kinds of cases you have to write
you know you write a formal letter on
stationery from your university this is
who I am this is my background as many
stamped letters that attest to who you
are really help and this is what I
always tell my students you know the
president of the University the chair of
your department the more sort of
official because you know Europe in some
ways is more hierarchical a sort of
status conscious than the US I mean here
you write to the National Archives
here's what I'm doing you know I wanted
to work on this subject and I'll be
there on this date but there you need
more to back you up in these former
communist regimes it also helped that
the Cold War international history
project based here in Washington had an
agreement with the key Central Committee
archive they will party archive in
Moscow for a conference and those of us
who were going to be presenting papers
at this conference got access so there I
was with you know a small group and I
didn't have to do anything on my own
which was very helpful and in that case
the Cold War project was you know giving
them some money and buying them
much-needed Xerox machines and you know
microfilm readers and this kind of thing
being a woman it's sort of a problem and
this is what I again I tell my women's
do
there's you have more of a need to prove
yourself in these kinds of places more
than need to come in with these stamped
letters and you know appear very serious
and being young you know I was
definitely younger at the time twelve
years ago and you know people they
didn't take you quite as seriously so it
was always the case for the first
several weeks especially in Moscow where
I was essentially proving myself and
there were bringing me mostly boring
stupid documents my favorite case they
brought me a stack of documents what was
it New York Times translated into
Russian you know this had been top
secret then I said thank you very much
but you know I could get that in the
West and I did not come to Moscow for
that of course you can't say it that way
but that's what I was thinking so at the
beginning it was real pressure on me to
prove myself and coming from the West so
being young being a woman coming from
the West they're all thinking and again
you with the spy museum will appreciate
this they're all thinking you're either
working for the CIA or for you know big
tabloid so you're looking for things and
the archives they're gonna make them
look bad and then you're gonna splash it
across the headlines that's what they
were thinking at first and particularly
the Central Committee archives where
they had not had many foreigners the
foreign ministry archives there had been
more foreigners there but in the Central
Committee the top party archive you know
I was a new occurrence and you know
they're sort of watching me and it was
only on my last day that they finally
got up the guts to ask me so all sorts
of questions most importantly how is it
that someone sort of so young could come
here like where did you get the money at
which point I said you know my
university and they looked at me because
Russian universities don't have
fellowships they don't have the money to
send their students going off on
research trips around the world so again
they you know you sense that they sort
of didn't believe me because they don't
know that they haven't seen that they
don't have private foundations giving
fellowships to graduate students so I
explained all of this and so you start
to feel you know you're sort of a
cultural ambassador and you're trying to
explain what the education system is
like in the United
States and how different it is the other
crazy experience they had also when that
archive was with my laptop computer
which was again sort of new for them and
the archivist I was working with you
know she would come out and bring me
some documents and put the documents
down next to my laptop and I'd be typing
when I bothe Cyrillic in English and
she's looking at my screen and she's
seeing the Cyrillic and she's seeing the
documents here and she finally says you
know how does this work and it's clear
she thinks it works by osmosis that
somehow these documents being near the
computer sort of sucking in these
documents so you know I mean terra
incognita which was one of the wonderful
things about being one of the first
people there but it also meant you I had
it was longer because they had to
develop trust in me and get to
understand that I was a serious scholar
it was a fascinating experience though
I'll tell you that
in conducting your research what was the
most surprising or most unexpected piece
of information that you came across the
biggest surprise was what I've talked
about at some length here the arrogance
of the East German leader the the degree
of it just really surprised me
and that the Soviet leader kept putting
up with this many people ask me why
didn't they just get rid of this guy
ohlbrecht if he was driving them so nuts
and he wasn't moderating his policies
the way they kept ask him to why didn't
they just get rid of him and it's
basically because of who Khrushchev was
that he felt he would look bad and that
you know the whole world was watching
and it would be sort of an admission of
defeat so the biggest surprise really
was the nature of that relationship and
that ohlbrecht had the confidence
sometimes the arrogance and really the
persistence to not give up
so that general dynamic and then some of
the specific documents I talked about
but particularly that letter when he
says you know why is this the case you
know it's your fault that's because of
post-world War two Soviet reparations
policy I mean that's incredible to me
that he was writing that to the Soviet
leader and getting away with it the
questions one right here
what happened to the eastern leadership
who has been on trial after the wall
fell were they convicted or varying
things the the man Erich Honecker who
had been the leader from 71 to 89 and
who had in fact had been in charge of
closing the border for of walter
ulbricht because he was the number two
for all bricked he was suddenly old and
sick even though he'd been ruling the
country until recently and actually I
think he got liver cancer and so he was
on trial for a very short time and then
they let him go for health reasons at
one point he fled to Moscow than the
Soviets sent him back and you know put
him on trial and finally for health
reasons they let him go and in fact they
let him go to join his daughter in Chile
where he lived for another couple of
years that makes a lot of people very
upset that sort of the top guy
essentially was led off the other top
guy Erik Milka who'd been head of the
secret police the Stasi similar thing he
again old and increasingly feeble and
had some health problems and they
couldn't one of the problems of the
Western legal system you know the demand
for very specific evidence and even
though he'd been head of the secret
police that was as they said the sword
and the shield of the party and really
kept the Communist Party in power and
enforced the board a regime and all of
that the best thing they could get him
on was evidence that he had taken part
in the murder of two German police in
1931 again people are very unhappy with
that so he was ultimately led off for
health reasons the the more recent top
Politburo guys Egon Krenz who said don't
blame us blame the Soviets was sentence
to something like seven and a half years
in jail
of which he served for others got two or
three years in jail
border guard trials were very
interesting because
of course it's the leaders the political
leaders who made the decision you must
shoot people trying to escape but it's
the border guards who pulled the trigger
so they also went on trial this was very
complicated because of course they could
say I was following orders which is
quite problematic in Germany after the
Nazi period you know using that defense
isn't great but of course there is a
certain justification to it most of the
border guards got sentences but then
we're let off on probation so for many
people there's there's a sense that the
trials have been more about exposing
sort of the evils of the East German
regime and getting it out there for
history to know and then mostly letting
the people go it's also been very
complicated because it's not the East
Germans who've been carrying out the
trials because the East German regime
collapsed it's been the United Germany
but who were the main judges and lawyers
are of course West Germans because it's
the West German legal system that took
over so there have been tinges of what
some East Germans have called Victor's
justice you know it's not fair it was
legal then we were supposed to shoot
people you know was on the books you
know that we were allowed to but now
you're trying us by other standards and
you know you've taken over our country
and it's a very complicated yet
interesting situation which is in fact
why it's a big part of my next book so
that's that's an answer over here this
may be the subject of your next book but
or the first chapter at least but as we
all know in Washington spin controls a
big thing did you see anything in your
research that you know was the either
the East German or the the Soviet spin
control as far as public perception
things like that that you know you found
interesting yeah during this crisis over
Berlin there were many times when
sort of the main way the Communists were
talking about it was we need German
unification and the West is refusing
this it's all the West fought that
Germany is divided we need German
unification and and we also need finally
a peace treaty to end World War two and
at one point
Albrecht the leader of East Germany said
you know what really plays far better
than talking about these things is
talking about the threat of West German
nuclear weapons because in the late 50s
NATO was starting to deploy some nuclear
weapons in West Germany and there was a
big question how much control were the
West Germans gonna have over these and
needless to say after World War Two the
Soviets were very afraid of any German
militarism and certainly West German
militarism and but it was clear that the
East German leader was saying look for
propaganda in Germany the way we really
can get people on our side is by
emphasizing this threat from West
Germany getting nuclear weapons that's
our in the most clear case I think of
where they talked purely for you know
propaganda for the public okay well
thank you for a very spirited animated
presentation it made for a delight to me
driving the soviets up the wall is
published by rowman & littlefield
on the web at roman littlefield calm